by air by land and by sea all routes
lead to this southern city beautiful
scenery and sunny skies attract many
additional residents each year
unfortunately this climate is also ideal
for one of man's worst enemies the Aedes
aegypti mosquito carrier of dengue and
yellow fever
to combat this menace to the city an
officer of the United States Public
Health Service cooperated with the local
health department one of the first steps
in the campaign was to discover
permanent mosquito breeding places such
as old cisterns basin shallow wells fire
barrels and numerous other containers
capable of holding what health officials
had constantly warned the people of
these dangerous conditions and of the
way mosquitoes spread to smaller
receptacles after a period devoted to
study and surveys the extent of breeding
of the dengue and yellow fever mosquito
was determined a special meeting of
health officials set in motion the anti
mosquito campaign it was decided that a
concerted effort would be necessary and
listing the aid of every source of
publicity together with the organized
individual efforts of all the people
with the health of an entire city in
jeopardy
the mayor promptly issued a proclamation
regarding the urgency of the situation
and asked that everyone participate in
eliminating the dengue yellow fever
mosquito
newspapers prove particularly valuable
in awakening the public to an
understanding of their common danger and
mutual dependence
officials of civic organizations
assisted the health officers in
recruiting leaders and obtaining
cooperation from the public through
knowledge rather than action and forced
by law
sandurz exhibited short films showing
methods of control of the dengue and
yellow fever mosquito Aedes aegypti
teamwork was stimulated in schools as a
direct result of the educational
programs which included the showing of
motion pictures on mosquitos their life
habits and various methods of control
children are impressed by this method of
presentation such knowledge acquired by
these citizens of tomorrow will be of
great influence in the building of
healthy prosperous communities of
tomorrow
progress of the campaign was broadcast
daily by local radio stations this
method was most effective in reaching
the housewife the self-appointed
guardian of the family welfare whose
cooperation is vital to the success of
any health campaign instructions and
educational material were supplied to
the Boy Scouts since they had
volunteered to inspect homes and tell
the people about the hazards of the city
districts were set up based on geography
and population as an additional
incentive for action it was decided to
give a bee merit award to cooperating
residents pamphlets on the Aedes aegypti
mosquito were made available for
distribution to every home together with
an instruction sheet showing methods of
destroying their breeding places and
posters urging definite action newspaper
publicity gave the necessary day-by-day
stimulus for a successful campaign
schoolchildren were eager to take part
in the mosquito control program since
they had been so fairly informed of its
importance
teachers emphasized the necessity of the
campaign by personally distributing
literature for the children to take home
parents were interested and realized the
need for eliminating the dengue and
yellow fever mosquito they welcomed
instructions on how to get rid of
mosquitoes in and around their homes a
call to arms found the Boy Scouts
prepared and anxious to undertake their
duties after being instructed by their
leader they started on their way to
distribute pamphlets and inspect
premises
the scouts greeted housewives in their
usual polite manner and consequently
received cooperation and assistance each
Scout had received instructions about
possible breeding places and was
determined to make a thorough inspection
of each home this attitude often
stimulated a housewife's concern and
careful observation if it holds water it
will hold mosquito larvae
another home another scout and another
housewife
the water in this container is fresh
there are no larvae here but they could
develop within a few days but let's look
in other containers ah here they are
who would imagine so many larvae in such
a small piece of pottery
any container capable of catching water
is a potential mosquito breeding place
and should be immediately destroyed or
emptied and turned bottoms up a careful
search is necessary to find the hidden
containers which provide permanent
breeding places larvae become mosquitoes
mosquitoes carry disease
inside or outside it makes no difference
man-made container is small and large
harbour Aedes aegypti mosquito larvae
discarded containers of this type should
always be given to salvage and garbage
collectors without delay constant
protection of the family health demands
constant vigilance
all drinking fans should be emptied and
washed at least twice a week mosquitoes
breed continually and are most prolific
one mosquito being able to lay hundreds
of eggs within a single day
after each home had been thoroughly
inspected the co-operative housewife was
given a merit award display of this
award was evidence of her intention to
continue keeping her home free from
dengue and yellow fever mosquito
informative articles published in the
newspapers were effective in making
housewives conscious of mosquito
breeding places the effect of this
information was often instantaneous
horrified
no wonder such a small plant and all
those wiggle tails in the water
all water plant receptacles in the home
should be emptied and scrubbed
twice a week
the stems of the plant should be
carefully rinsed to remove any remaining
mosquito larvae a simple operation
indeed but only by such precautions can
any home be kept free of the disease
carrying Aedes aegypti mosquitoes
since most water plants grow well in
soil it was recommended that where
possible the change be made potted
plants never breed mosquitoes
Girl Scouts were enlisted in the all-out
campaign they discovered and destroyed
numerous breeding places including those
in cemeteries in order to stimulate
greater interest in the collection and
destruction of mosquito larvae
schoolchildren were encouraged to
collect the wiggle tails and feed them
to minnows such action also emphasized
the importance of fish as a protective
measure minnows like these when placed
in garden pools and similar places each
mosquito larvae
every section of the city was thoroughly
inspected vacant plots were found with
accumulations of refuse the scouts
punched holes in containers to make sure
they would never again be capable of
holding water and mosquito larvae
community cooperation is essential in
all health education programs since
cleanup in one area contributes to the
welfare of the entire community mosquito
larvae are often found in unsuspected
places such as old discarded tires
containing water there's just about one
efficient way to get water out of these
tires and this is it
after the water is removed from such
tires they should be stored in dry
sheltered locations until salvage this
man by cooperating in the campaign
helped protect the health of his family
and neighbors there by receiving the
merit award thousands of rusty damaged
containers were promptly removed from
homes by the city sanitary department
this is one of the most effective
methods for the permanent elimination of
mosquito breeding places a brief survey
of the huge collection was made by
health and sanitary officials before
salvaging or destruction
posters were displayed throughout the
city to keep the public ever mindful of
the mosquito menace
store owners contributed window space
for unusual exhibits conveying to the
public the danger of mosquito breeding
various methods of Aedes Egypt eye
control were presented the display of
live mosquitoes and larvae attracted the
attention of thousands of people
the larvae eating minnows impressed many
spectators as being an effective way to
combat the mosquito hazards the aroused
public attitude assured the success of
the anti mosquito campaign
you have just observed how one city
awakened to the potential danger of
uncontrolled dengue and yellow fever
mosquito breeding and cooperated in an
urgent community project by organizing
the entire population of the city
immediate results were obtained and
citizens continued the control program
to ensure permanent freedom from dengue
and yellow fever
every community has a wealth of
resources but its greatest resource is
its people capable leaders can develop
the power and the ability of the people
to assure a victorious mosquito control
program it's up to you
you